welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and how can this guy and this guy
come from the same damn Studio the
recent episode of the mandalorians
surprise viewers with the live-action
VFX rendering of Zeb from the animated
Star Wars Rebels that looks really good
it's a comforting nerd win for the pfx
fatigue we've been feeling after titles
like Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
with its floating uncanny valley in the
form of Modoc the results of a
reportedly chaotic and rushed VFX
process now I analyzed modox VFX and I
pointed out how wow critics compared it
to George Lopez and Sharkboy and Lava
Girl in 3D modox appearance really
improves later in the movie when his
crown is broken so that his face doesn't
look as boxed in and whenever his head
is turned to the side with more
texturing Zeb meanwhile benefits from
less screen time and backlighting the
camera only stays on him for a few
seconds at a time in a scene that lasts
only about a minute and in that time the
artist did some impressive texturing
like notice how as Zeb talks you can see
the wrinkles in his nose and the muscles
around his Temple twitching these
artists really accomplished what the
artists who worked on Avengers Infinity
war did with Thanos they crafted a skull
with additional layers of facial muscles
and ligaments under semi-translucent
skin that they textured with wrinkles
and hairs to make all of it look
lifelike and interact really well with
the light of the room but if both Marvel
Studios and lucasfilm are owned by
Disney with the same supposedly spare no
expense budget for effects paid for by
all the churros I buy at Disneyland why
are these two wings of the House of
Mouse so far apart well some of Marvel's
VFX artists have said they've been
feeling stretched thin and a little
embarrassed to see their names of the
credits of these movies when the work is
going out unfinished and everyone makes
fun of it but we should acknowledge that
the bfx houses who work on all of these
titles are extremely talented ilm WETA
digital domain frame store Cantina
creative they're all Cutting Edge
technologists and Visionaries who don't
get enough credit for the art they
create so when we compare modak and
quantumania to Zeb in the Mandalorian
let's take off the table that technology
and talent could it all be to blame for
the discrepancy like I'm sure the
artists in the industry have opinions on
which teams and houses are doing the
best work but overall they seem to share
a common respect for each other and
would agree that they are all capable of
greatness but there are four differences
that lead to why Modoc looks like this
on an iMac screen while Zeb looks like
this on streaming despite all the
buffering that Disney plus does to it
and I think these four differences get
to the core distinction between the
cultures of Marvel and Star Wars right
now difference number one time and
budget the VFX artist who worked on
Marvel said that they had to work on
black panther one kind of forever and
Ant-Man the WASP Quantum media at the
same time and we're told to prioritize
wakanda forever while putting Quantum
Mania on the back burner meanwhile the
artists working at lucasfilm and ilm on
these Eight Episodes of the Mandalorian
season 3 were probably not under the
same pressure yes there were animated
series like the bad batch and tales of
the Jedi but lucasfilm is not releasing
theatrical films right now and that's a
big deal over on the Deep dive I
explored how Marvel's sudden increase of
output in 2021 and 2022 really led to
this now in 2023 they seem to be
reverting to the norm difference number
two operations and business structure a
huge difference between Marvel and Star
Wars is the business relationship
between the artist in the studio at
Lucasville most of the pfx work is done
by ilm industrial Light magic that's
George Lucas's effects company ilm will
sometimes help out with other non-lucas
phone Productions too like Marvel and
Pixar but they really are lucasfilm's
in-house artist team they're led by
artists who grew up with the original
Star Wars films and the prequels and now
the entry-level artists working there
are at an age where they probably grew
up with clone wars and Rebels so
animating a live-action Zeb is their
dream project now a lot of people have
given up on being good at sleep but it's
only because they don't realize what a
difference good sleep gear Makes You Can
level up your sleep game overnight with
Helix sleep Helix sleep makes premium
mattresses embedding customized to fit
your needs and shipped right to your
door and look I'm not a sleepologist or
anything but I don't need to be Helix
has a sleep quiz that matches your
unique body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you you can even take it with a partner
and find the mattress that is a perfect
compromise between your preferences I
took the quiz with my wife we wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and now that we're
newlyweds we upgraded to a dusk Lux
Helix mattress king size we just
unrolled it and you know what we
completely love it we we're both
sleeping better we wake up less often
than we used to and again Helix delivers
your mattress order right to your door
for free it comes rolled up in a
shockingly tiny box and it's super easy
to set up yourself Helix has a 100 night
sleep trial so you'll get more than
three months to make sure that you love
your mattress and if you don't they'll
pick it up for you and you'll get a full
refund and these mattresses also have a
10 year warranty that's an entire decade
Helix even has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great night
of sleep is never far away I love my
Helix and I think you would too if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix you can click the link below or go
to helixsleep.com new rockstars to get
20 off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows meanwhile Marvel has
increasingly outsourced the bulk of
their effects work to separate VFX
houses because their films have so much
complexity effects going into them one
of the biggest companies who does this
is WETA FX formerly WETA digital a new
zealand-based company founded by Peter
Jackson for Heavenly Creatures and went
on to do the amazing effects of The Lord
of the Rings trilogy and both of James
Cameron's Avatar film but the VFX needs
for Marvel Studios have just grown and
grown like comparing the VFX teams and
the credits for the recent episode of
the Mandalorian you got one page of the
DFX crew from ilm one page for the
virtual projection team at ilm
stagecraft and one page for the virtual
environment design from narwhal Studios
but then look at the VFX credits on the
She-Hulk finale it's insane
visualization by the third floor Inc
digital effects and animation by digital
domain visual effects and animation by
WETA FX visual effects by Wiley Co
visual effects and animation by
trickster visual effects by Katina
created visual effects by fuse FX visual
effects by sdfx Studios visual effects
by capital T visual effects by keep you
posted a photo cam company visual
effects by Soho VFX Ingenuity Studios
light stage motion captured by the
imaginarian studios 4D facial
performance capture by d14d I'm not
making fun of these companies they are
all great and amazing but there are just
so many of them and they're all
competing against each other for the
same contracts now to be fair the
She-Hulk finale had a lot of moving
Parts going on there you had multiple
hulks all in a brawl with each other you
had She-Hulk crashing through the Disney
plus home screen you had the whole Kevin
sequence you got any post credit scene
with a teenage Hulk but compare She-Hulk
to House of the Dragons finale which had
an extended stormy Dragon Battle and it
looked awesome and that episode's
credited VFX teams include virtual
Production Services by Lux Machina
visual effects by NPC episodic visual
effects by piximondo that was really the
majority of the artists who worked on
this previous by the third floor Inc and
then smaller teams from Viridian
Peerless and incessant rain that's
really it if you count all the names
it's less than half of the artist
working on she-hulk's finale in House of
the Dragons finale was double the length
in Malcolm gladwell's the Tipping Point
he quotes some industry leaders that 150
people is the maximum size a company
should grow to since the human mind
supposedly only has the bandwidth of
containing familiar relationships with a
maximum of 150 people after that we
start to forget names and bases so
hundreds and hundreds of artists working
on one single movie or TV show while it
has worked for Marvel in the past it's
clearly not scalable it results in too
many projects losing a cohesive vision
and it produces burnouts so these
artists run to the media to vent
anonymously comparatively at lucasfilm
and ilm all of these artists are
in-house and they are so proud of what
they make I was lucky to attend the
Mandalorian Premiere event in Los
Angeles with the cast and crew and you
could hear the excitement of these
artists in the room when the mythosar
floated up on screen people screamed and
you can totally see that company culture
on screen the casting Obama at best the
shout out to Jeremy Bullock and Dave
Maloney Deborah chow and Rick family you
were themselves sitting at the other end
of that bar from Zeb toasting him with
spachka now there's also a third
difference expectation management Marvel
wears their ambitious VFX on their
sleeve they heavily promoted a masked
Modoc in trailers and they made She-Hulk
the title character of that show sending
the viewers to raise expectations for
visual greatness and Marvel leans on VFX
for their final battles of their stories
the DFX is the spectacle it's the reason
you go watch it's the fireworks
meanwhile these Star Wars examples
surprise us with these gloves Shadow
cameos no one knew Zev was gonna show up
or that DH Luke Skywalker was going to
show up these guys pop by for brief
cameos and before we have time to form
an opinion about how good their bfx
looks they're gone and then the final
battle of most Star Wars titles is
almost always either a lightsaber duel
an aerial battle or a gunslinger duel or
all three they really keep it simple
with these classic intimate Delights
behind lightsabers or inside of cockpits
which leaves us with the fourth
difference viewer psychology at this
point Marvel's biggest problem is that
viewers expect there to be a lot of the
effects and for it to be bad viewers
don't even know what bad VFX is anymore
like I thought it was hilarious how some
people thought those giraffes in The
Last of Us finale were fake when they
were totally real giraffes just on a
blue screen viewers go into these things
believing that if they sense something
false about a shot anything false at all
then rather than just suspending their
belief in going with it they have to go
tweet how bad it is our open-mindedness
has been burned too many times but now
we just tune in bracing for
disappointment and I'm not blaming the
viewer here I'm saying this cynicism is
what the studios now have to overcome
they have to do what James Cameron is
doing and take their time to make
something truly undeniably great and
beautiful luckily for Star Wars they're
always going to have the benefit of an
asset Library five decades deep of ships
sound effects and music and so Longs
they include enough of those memories
it'll feel like Star Wars and will have
an open mind to the new stuff Marvel
meanwhile is the new kid on the Block
they got a lot to prove still and I
think ultimately what makes Zeb work the
best in that scene is that he's simply
just hanging out with a bunch of X-Wing
and y-wing pilots in a bar a bar with
the same kind of kegs as the most Eisley
Cantina Bar with a bunch of Star Wars
Easter eggs everywhere and no one has to
know who this random guy is to enjoy
this moment Star Wars isn't always
perfect but when they pull off this move
they're always gonna crush it and at the
end of the day I think that's why we all
like Zip better hey a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and he can support us by grabbing
some merch at nerd riot.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you